okay here we are back on back on James
under the Homeland Security Industrial
Complex is going after Isis viewed as a
source of profit Oh already already big
profit from Isis right yeah well I think
what I Pentagon what I think that what
we have is 13 years of endless war we've
had since 9/11 right
basically 9/11 after 9/11 we started
with a search for justice now 13 years
later the war on terror has kind of
become a search for cash and yeah and
you know we always find a new threat I
mean granted Isis is serious but we
don't have to transform our whole
society just because of every insurgent
group around the world and we have to
begin to realize these groups while
they're dangerous they're not
existential threats to the United States
they're not reasons for us to allow a
whole national security state to be
developed you know who was right was I
mean this guy by the way is a real hero
the journey yeah no question about but
but you know Eisenhower's Milton
military-industrial complex Beach looks
better and more important with every
passing year and and that speech really
should go in the cannon is something we
study right and and for him to do it as
a general he was the one guy who could
warn us with real credibility and and
it's only become more of a problem right
that whole idea of been you know we
could call we could put that under the
category of Nixon to China yeah if
people who can do things that nobody
else can do or few other can do because
they have this sort of special
credibility born of something they did
centrist leaders it does why doesn't
that work for guns Reagan got hot he
could have said hey I have a bullet in
me um Gabby Giffords you know there she
still says I'm a strong supporter of the
Second Amendment uh what does it take to
change us on the gun thing well Reagan
supported the Brady Bill I mean Mary
will remember this and actually when you
raise that inconvenient fact to
conservatives today they get real pissed
but but there it is
and in part because of his compassion
and the experience of James Brady so the
fact that we can't get background checks
things that really had bipartisan
support before when you get 90%
support the American people that's a
sickness and it's how men was the
Congress are so goddamn scared of
lobbyists that they'll run the other way
despite 90 percent of the American
people want something else
there's actually a lot of things about
st. regan peace and blessings upon him
that but that are inconvenient truths
yeah like he cut and run at 11:00 on
like he was for amnesty like he wanted
nuclear weapons down there there's a
bashing bush so you're gonna go back to
reagan i'm actually praising Reagan I'm
actually czar the things I love about
him
you know but they're the ones that get
swept under the rug or the convenient
rewriting of history you're right about
the way he dealt with terrorism was much
more realistic and pragmatic right like
we're getting the [ __ ] out of here yeah
I gotta tell you that was just there is
a real when people got the message that
you could hit Americans once and loving
them to barracks and they would retreat
that does send a message and that does
inspire a lot of ugly people who think
they can intimidate us by attacking us
and and that does create that cycle got
started and what people can argue was
evident Janet and it would have been
better if we had stayed in Lebanon
that's the problem with being a Dunning
you're an empire not a republic but when
you don't respond to that or you respond
in that way and you cumulative Lee then
don't respond to the East African
embassy bombings you don't respond to
the USS Cole bombing you don't respond
we did respond a number but the problem
the problem is though that if you what
we are now going down we're going down
the road that Israel is going down which
is to have a cycle of violence you
attack we attack you we respond to every
attack and there is no end to that
unless we have some clear defined goals
in the war on terror and that's where we
lack right now is a clear endpoint what
are we trying to achieve correct Argo
iron game now is don't do stupid stuff I
believe your candidate for the next
presidential race it I'm in agreement
with you some situations particularly
foreign policy national security have to
be managed they can't be solved this is
a problem it's been going on millennium
millennia and we go because we're
Americans and there's no exclusive
province to either party we go to
solution instead of management we did
respond to the embassy bombings Clinton
sent a cruise missile and blew up a
pharmaceutical factory in Sudan so he
was he was attacking the wrong country
before it was cool Mary's bluff
destroying its route that was actually
one for you Democrats blame Mary this
person says blame the do-nothing
Congress on the Republicans what is the
Republican rebuttal to that
well the opposition party is to oppose
but I would also say something you
probably don't know texture that 370
pieces of bipartisan legislation were
passed out of the House Energy
immigration tax reform Court sitting
where major pieces 370 which a lot of
major stuff was inside the bipartisan
bipartisan look it up I don't make a
good not Paul Krugman this is true okay
what Keystone pipeline reforms to ACA
corporate and individual tax reform
these are bipartisan bipartisan the
center this is bipartisan like the way
it was when the Louisiana Republican
voted for the ACA and Nancy Pelosi said
it was bipartisan this is not I mean a
well oh you know yeah it would happen
when we take over the Senate and Harry
Reid is not constipating this
legislation like oh it gets done I'm
just kidding in your veneer I mean the
record we've seen frankly is that
whenever the only time anything gets
done is when Boehner ditches the Hastert
rule which by the way is [ __ ] in the
first place because even Hastert says it
wasn't real thing and every time the
president actually tries to reach out
support the roads from positions that
Republicans supported in the past
because he's considered politically
toxic by Republicans this our president
democratic erosion at this point yeah we
know we could talk about Southern
Democrats and all that done it there's a
question I've asked also so it's
interesting to me what does it really
matter who wins the Senate next month
won't there be a filibuster prevent
anything from being done I've asked that
question I asked
think of Nancy Pelosi well hey there's
not a filibuster it depends with the
makeup of this the Senate yeah yeah if
if the makeup of the Senate is more of
the same in conjunction with the
upcoming 2016 race no things will we'll
just stay in this in this gridlock
however the founders divined gridlock
they want us to when we're not
interested they didn't want this money I
there's a difference between compromise
and consensus compromise is Solomon's
baby and you end up with inferior
product if you get data-driven outcome
based consensus like they do at Google
like they do at every why are you
talking about
no the country is based unprincipled
compromise the Constitution is based on
principle compressed we've had divided
government a ton before including the
90s we always gotten a lot done no
principles there the problem is
compromise has become a dirty word and
and you know you want to look at where
the bridge is gonna get zealous I mean
looked at looking know if Gregoire min
the independent from Kansas gets elected
and angus King an independent from Maine
and all of a sudden you got a coalition
of folks could be the balance of power
maybe that'll restore some of the
ability to build bipartisan bridges but
we have the least productive least
popular Congress in American history
right now and it's because they're so
divided they're totally dysfunctional
it's a break with American history it's
not a continuation of it thank you folks